so
uh bernie you're a giants fan you're a
jets guy i mean let's bring this back to
you you're from new york you ran new
york
for a freaking decade you know i'm i'm
not a big football
fan uh you know i i like the giants
because they're in new york
um you know i like the yankees uh
i used to go to i usually attended a
bunch of games i don't
i don't go anymore not uh not happy with
the nfl and some of these other teams
that have
supported black lives matter and all
this nonsense
um so i've kind of stayed away from it
gotcha so not not a bo jackson fan maybe
what bo jackson yeah
i like him good man good guy okay
now but you were a football fan before
like you were a guy that followed
football i would follow it yeah so you
went from following now you're not
following it no
in the last three years the last two
strangers so you're that fan who says i
was a fan now i'm not
no so so is it fair to say if i go to
red con today at five o'clock
hypothetically and you're there kai
greene is there
aaron is there you guys are working out
i'm probably not going to see in a
kaepernick jersey is that is that a
first session that's pretty fair to say
that's pretty fair so what did you do
you will not
see me working out with kai greene and
aaron yeah i'll be by myself by yourself
those boys are on their own yeah they're
they're off to this i mean first of all
kai just
kai looks like uh aaron's a big guy
aaron aaron's a big guy
but kai is a a monster
yeah so i i gotta tell you he went to uh
i took him to cpac with me
right the conservative political action
committee uh event and um
he wanted to go he wanted to go to see
kai greene kai greene
which i don't know for me it was
surprising this is a brooklyn dude
wants to go to cpac i said all right so
aaron and i and aaron's wife and uh and
kai
we go to cpac and uh you know i know a
bunch of these guys that
you know former universe former
olympians
but i've never hung with them like at
dinner
at lunch so we go in this we go in this
restaurant
and we sit down to have lunch and
aaron's wife orders like a sandwich and
aaron orders a cheeseburger and i
order a cheeseburger and kai
he says okay i'll take a uh a
cheeseburger
and um with um you know
those red fries and a and a chicken
sandwich too
and um and in a big salad
and um in that in that in the in another
sandwich
this is kai this is kai and the ladies
the ladies looking at him and she goes
oh
is or do we need another c is somebody
else coming
and he goes uh no that's for me it's for
me i do 12 lunches well let me see how
much he weighs
this guy is 310 pounds how tall he's
five eight
five yeah i was gonna say he's he's
about five eight
have you seen what he looks like kai's
physique let's pull him up can you can
you put it you gotta you gotta beat it's
got your name
so he's he sits there and he has this
you know this lunch for five on his own
he sits there
much for five for one yeah look yeah
he's a small
guy he's got the beautiful rat tail he's
a small dude
and so so we get done we get done with
that lunch
yeah and we go on to the vip room in in
the
in the cpac center and about an hour
later
we're in that room and he's like tooling
around the room and he's looking in the
little
you know they have the hors d'oeuvre
things and i said to aaron i said what's
he looking for
he said he's hungry i see he's hungry
yeah he just got enough [ __ ] food for
about
30 people yeah that's he's hungry that's
insane
again let the boy eat let the boy eat
that's him but
but they they do you know they have six
eight meals a day to maintain that
physique and weight you need it
well you're considering doing something
like that you said no no no no no no not
not working out like that no no but
eating more small meals
this is not they're not eating sick
small meals these guys are eating six
cows a day because it was what he's
telling you is he
let's get some clothes the bottom line
is just you can eat
you know and i went through this in my
turmoil
i learned how to eat six eight times a
day
but it was super small meals um
you know and and you know they have
everybody has these diets right they
have a hundred different diets
here's the diet the real diet protein
vegetables and fruit i don't know what
the hell you call that
you know they got names diet yeah paleo
and all these other
cavemen it's all bs protein
vegetables and fruit if you do that you
do it in small portions
six to eight times a day you will knock
off the weight
you'll be in phenomenal shape and uh you
know that's that's kind of what uh
what i would that's not kai's diet kai
is trying to maintain
three ten three hundred pounds this
guy's eating this guy's eaten
think about it i mean he's eating four
thousand calories
per meal per meal yeah your
time six meals but he spends he spends
eight hours a day in the gym for him to
maintain that physique well he's been
doing movies
he he took a different route he went
from doing the bodybuilding side to now
he no longer competes he is more doing
movies hollywood he took a different
route
and have you have you ever met him no i
got it you got to get him on the show
i'm telling you smart guy you know just
soft spot
strong opinions or no pretty strong
opinions
um but he's he's a soft-spoken guy
not the nicest man you can meet
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
[Music]
bye-bye